hi
welcome to the meditation class
the film i made uh talking to the
general aikido world
that uh will be on here as well
it's not just a teaser so that's got the
first
explanation in in that and i've done
this up
really close so that you can sort of
watch facial muscles and things
if you're interested you see i don't
know what makes me think this but
i've been meditating for i can't
remember how many years
let's say 34 years
and i only do it when i feel like it and
i'm not that regular but when i was 23
so if you can
just bear with us it's not going to ruin
your life to
to listen to it and if you're
open-minded enough to
hear me out you may find some value in
it
i didn't start out i started at 23
in aikido and i didn't start out
believing in
god religion the afterlife or anything
like that
and i and i still don't
i believe less in religion now than i
did then
but my sister insisted that i went to
see
a psychic this old lady in oxford
because i wanted to take on a large
business venture
and it could have been a make or break
situation because i was going to have to
buy
a lot of money anyway i didn't believe
in that sort of thing at all
and i went along um only because she
kept
pushing me and i i had the fear of
making the wrong decision and at that
age
your ego is pretty strong so you're
pretty determined about what we want to
do
and now to shorten this story i went
along and she told me things that
i wouldn't even give her my name when i
knocked on the door or
say anything because i didn't want to
give anything away
so i go in there and this little old
lady in her
i think late 70s sat in this bay window
opened the back of cards and she looked
at she told me
about this car franchise i wanted to
take on
not to do it wouldn't be successful just
be hard work
cause a lot of problems wouldn't make
money wouldn't lose money
but it's not worth doing it and she
actually changed my life at that point
because in years
on i did take on car franchises
but when i was in a much better position
why am i telling you this i'm telling
you this that we all
have an ability in our mind
to have psychic awareness now what
am i going to be talking to you here
about your psychic
awareness and how will it help you in
your aikido
i've already said in the other video
that osensi
was a special person he talked
lots of stuff to the uh
students who become masters and were
brilliant in their art
but i think we all if you're like me
want to get closer to like o senses
aikido
because for some reason this magical
path that he seemed to be able to do
everything with ease but
he wrote a lot of poems short sayings
and he said the enemy is defeated
as they stand in front of him
to me he telepathically
knew what they were thinking or he knew
their hesitance
or their their positivity
he knew when they would strike he knew
when
um they would enter towards him
so they were already already defeated in
his opinion
so i'm going to take you through these
meditations that i've been talking about
but
but we're going to do it in several
sessions
so that you can try it build on it if
you wish
and start to understand that there's a
i'm talking to you my lips are moving
i'm talking to you
with what i'm going to call an outer
body
the whole body that you can see here all
of this
is going to be my outer body i can't
show you my
inner body but
it's a place the mind very rarely goes
but we all have it we all have
gut feelings
not sure about this you know we we
search it's almost like
there's a hidden uh cupboard that we
don't
bother to go to some some of you will
think well there's no need
i'm fine as i am others will think
yes but i don't know how to untap it i
don't know how to unlock
my psychic side
this is you finding a way of talking to
your
inner so your elder talks to your inner
and then you listen to your inner
to guide your elder i've touched on
these um
i've touched on these before
but i also said on the last
film that i've i've done throwing people
without touching them
some of my students have said oh don't
do that again since that hurts
you know where you deliver the imaginary
punch
you do the action with the outer body
but it doesn't ever hit the student but
the student
feels the punch they feel the the hit
i'm going to slowly teach you how to
start connecting your mind
where does this also help you in daily
life it helps you analyze
people because you'll go can i trust
this person
if you have your
inner mind open
and you know how to think correctly
you'll go should i trust this person
and you'll get a yes or no you're not
going to get a long conversation from
your inner self
at first you'll doubt it so ask it again
should i trust this person
i'm not getting a great feeling
why can't i trust them you might not get
any message back
because what's happening is your inner
self
is saying will you do a little bit of
work you
alter yourself you do a little bit of
work
i'm telling you be suspicious
now you've got to start looking and
investigating
why you should be suspicious
you don't we don't understand how
intelligent we are as a being
people who specialize in it may be
called freaks
it's because we can't see it we don't
believe in it
try to expand your mind
doing good strong techniques
are part of the package
but if you want to really get closer to
our scentsy
then you do need to learn how to listen
to your inner self and take note of it
because when a person comes a friendly
person on the tatami
with a can of joe taijitsu whatever it
may be
when that person is about to start
are you twitching are you trying to work
out
you know what to do when to move of
course you are because this is natural
if you don't are you arrogant is your
ego thinking it's so confident that you
can handle it
that's not a good way to long term
think but it's a way that
i would think at least 90 of the
aikidoka do think
they're not humble enough
i believe that mo sensei was connected
to his spiritual side
his own it's in us we don't have to go
drifting off to some you know religion
to find it
we hold this key i want to get that
firmly across to you you hold this key
of what i'm going to be talking about
i'm not going off
on any weird tangent to say that you've
got to believe in some
religion believe in yourself
and know that you've got to do a little
bit of work
to go there okay now the camera's really
close
and the reason it's close is i'm going
to show you
my stages so first of all i'm going to
i'm going to have to talk to you but
obviously you wouldn't be talking
there's other videos on how you learn to
get into your meditations
i'm just going to relax outward breath
relax my mind and try and get to a place
of emptiness
of nothing now i'm going to do a little
bit of movement
but but you don't have to do movement
but i'm just going to show you
relaxation
slowly close my eyes
as i breathe out my feeling is of
going down within myself
next breath out through the mouth of the
nose
i prefer the nose but it's up to you
i'm gonna go down again
facial muscles are getting softer
forehead is soft no tension
i'm going to keep doing this with my
mind going
without each outward breath allow the
breath to do itself you're just waiting
for the breath to go out and then when
it goes out
you just go down through your body
through your whole body your chest your
spine
you don't have to think about it you'll
feel it as you relax
you'll feel something in your body relax
so you're going down and
you know you can perhaps even drop like
this
i try not to do that but at first
you you do that it's almost like
dropping off to sleep
and just dropping off to sleep you're
doing it in this
seated position don't do it in the
laying position because we're
we're actively working we're working a
goal
of achieving something
now i'd like you to do so you're
watching me i'll
see you while we're doing this
and then you practice it afterwards
right so i've exhausted all the
opportunities of breathing out relaxing
i now feel like i'm in a state of very
calm
but there's nowhere else to go if you
know me i don't feel any
muscles relaxing in my legs or my body
or and i'm not going to start moving
about trying to get other bits to relax
i've just let it happen naturally and as
my outward breath goes i've just
relaxed relaxed
realized
what i'm going to do now is when i get
totally relaxed
i'm going to think with my mind
and i'm going to ask my own inner body
to show me a sign that i'm connected
with it
so i want to now be connected
my inner mind and my outer mind
my inner body and my outer body
don't get too confused
but i want to find the link the
connection
so i'm working as one
so i'm in the relaxed state and i'm
going to be waiting for something but
with my mind i'm going to say
please send me a connection keep it
short
now you could find one of your eyebrows
twitch
you could feel a small breeze on your
cheek i always get it on my right side
somewhere but never on my left but you
might get it in other places
you know you might find that something
happens you know you might get a
twitchy nose or
if you're unsure and you think oh that
might
it was so subtle i don't really know if
i
got a connection
just relax pause ask again
not with your voice remember i'm talking
to you but this is what i'm going to say
with my mind
please show me the connection
i'm going to repeat it as many times as
i wish in my mind
until i feel something
but do it in a relaxed mind not a
focused hard mind keep
calm do it in a relaxed mind
thank you now i've thanked the
connection
because i i felt the connection
you may do this 20 times and not feel
anything but is it because
you're not nothing's happening or
you're not sensitive enough you might be
closed off
like blinkered because you're trying
too hard to feel something so
the first stage is the total relaxation
the second stage is you might feel a
little breeze and you might think oh
perhaps there's a window open
don't put questions and answers in your
mind
just accept the first thing you feel
was it a twitch on my elbow eyebrow
did i feel something touch my ear
so once you've made that connection
then if you sit tomorrow or next month
and you do the same again you should
get the same ear
eyelash breeze so once you've made the
connection with your
inner self that will always stay with
you that
that will be the same so that's your
link
between you and your inner you
your l2u and your nau
we're going to go further in stages
and
what we're doing is we're going to
enhance
your zanchin your awareness
but the awareness must start with you
first
tomorrow sense he said don't teach
others until you've taught yourself
when i was on a seminar once
on the other film i said i went to
america
bob nadeau he was very much into
energy i've seen him do some amazing
things with
energy we can do more
than just techniques we can be more
aware
we can build up internal power we can
build up
the external power that the our partners
feel
but we have to do it use our mind in an
efficient way not a destructive way
or not in a way of want
you see i want to feel something on my
face i want to feel
attached or something i i need
i need to feel this these are desires
that
won't help you find where we're going
please be patient we're not going
anywhere
and in time we can advance so that you
can
fix on somebody try throwing without
touching your your inner mind will know
when that day is and when that's a bad
day to try it i've had people come up to
me and say scentsy
can i can you show me the pushing with
the sword
when you hold where you hold it one hand
and i push it sideways
and i can't push it and i go ah no i'm
not going to show that today
because i'm not my elders not connected
with my
inner then another day i'll go
i'll get the sword out and say to
somebody come to the side and push this
sword
and they can't move
they can't move the sword and it takes a
not great deal of effort on my part
it's because i'm mentally connected they
think they're pushing the sword but
really you've locked their mind
if you find this is not for you then i
understand
you don't have to but i do believe
with the pandemic and people
sensitivities
we need to look at more than just
technical aikido
we will still do aikido but we will
learn
how that we can live a better life
within ourself
and be a better martial artist
thanks for your time